last night at Toronto Fashion Week we
caught up with superstar Gigi gorgeous
who told us all about her recent wedding
to now wife
Nats Getty I promise to support you
through any challenges that come your
way I promise to be your shoulder to cry
on and most of all I promise to be your
person I love you knots and with every
beat of my heart I will love you more
and more I wish I could do it all over
again like I never really thought that I
would get married but now that I am it
just feels really right my favorite part
of the wedding definitely hands down was
my family her family and all of our
friends being in one location for a
whole weekend so we could all really
like mingle and get to know each other
so now that it's official what has
surprised Gigi the most about married
life nothing has changed but I think
people are always like oh yeah like
what's going on like you know how are
you guys acting whatever but I think
it's just it's just a title that makes
me feel more secure in my relationship
and I love her more than ever and
I'm ready to spend the rest of my life
with her it's so sweet
Gigi was at Toronto Fashion Week's
xposed event which exhibited a photo
series of Gigi hailing her an icon in
the making for me somebody that's an
icon isn't just in the moment they speak
towards themselves the past and the
future and it's about overcoming things
that are really really hard for you like
nobody who is gonna be an icon has just
had an easy fluffy life everybody who's
gone through things overcome them shared
their stories and really just like
embraced everybody going through the
same thing I think that's what my icons
are made up of the photos were shot by
incredible fashion photographer Chris
Nichols and the series was inspired by
Gigi's own journey to becoming her true
self the photos are insane I mean
honestly when I first saw them I was not
ready I was like wow I look so different
it's almost like I'm transitioning again
like I'm transforming again into
something else like a 60s icon in the
making if you will
so do you feel Gigi is an icon in the
making I sure do what do you love about
Gigi I love her spirit and candidness
she was actually right here on ET Canada
pride a few months ago and let me tell
you she is good people did your eyes
also water at Gigi and Nats wedding
footage like mine did let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page
[Music]